ce monde tout le monde actuellement
reprend un peu le mode horde et gilet
jaune est tout simplement parce que
c'est c'est toute la france qui parle
aussi donc c'est normal qu'un parti
politique soit au courant de la colère
de son pays et c'est normal qu'un parti
politique potosi les mots d'ordre de qui
sont renvoyés par la population c'est
tout à fait normal
les axiaux les réponses proposées par le
gouvernement par ici par le conseil
régional ne sont pas suffisantes ne sont
pas visibles le mans puisque la colla là
puisque la mobilisation continue
visiblement ce n'est pas encore à la
hauteur il ya encore il ya encore des
choses et encore des choses à voir
mais quand même il faut dire qu'à qu'il
y a des propositions en face les on ne
peut pas dire que les politiques restent
sans rien faire il y a quand même des
propositions mais on le voit bien
vous me posez la question mais vous
voyez bien que çà çà çà çà marche pas
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire selon
vous pour lutter notamment contre la
cherté au caire à la réunion
effectivement c'est le projet c'est le
problème qui a été mis sur le
sur le devant et les solutions qui ont
été proposées malheureusement sont un
peu là les mêmes depuis depuis des
années se comparer à la france toujours
donner un petit peu plus ou retirer un
petit peu alors que c'est tout un tout
un système qu'il faut revoir
nous on est à la réunion on est dans
l'océan indien
on est une petite île et on est tout le
temps comparé à la france on doit tout
le temps comparé les prix des produits à
des produits qui arrivent de de 11000 km
donc là il ya peut-être une autre façon
de voir les choses le bail est l'aide au
fret dans la continuité territoriale
proposée par part personnellement je ne
suis pas pour cette idée parce que
quelque part on aide qui quand on quand
on paye les frais c'est pas pas
forcément les réunionnais et est ce que
c'est vraiment ça le problème ce n'est
pas sûr parce que je les les écrans de
l'écran ni les grands magasins les
grandes distributions ici font les prix
qu'ils veulent pas en fait unis font ici
une aide ou pas ils proposent des prix
qu'ils vont proposer les prix qu'ils
voudront d'ailleurs il ya déjà des
magasins la réunion qui font des prix
ils appellent ça prix métropole donc qui
est une aide ou pas ça veut dire que
c'est possible
ils peuvent faire les prix alignés sur
la métropole si c'est ce qu'on veut donc
c'est pas une aide au fret qui va
changer les choses
donc c'est à mon avis peut-être bien
voir le prix de revient de la production
quand un produit arrive ici que ce
produit coûte 20 euros alors que il est
importé d'un pays qui est juste à côté
et qu'il coûte 2 euros
là il ya un problème et ça c'est pas le
frais qui va changer les choses fait à
payer le fret c'est ce sont encore les
réunionnais qui vont les bus qui vont
payer qui vont payer ça je ne suis pas
pour cette solution
et en plus ben sassi serre entre m6 et
l'europe qui paye
même si c'est l'europe qui paye parce
que là on est qui on est de la grande
distribution je suis désolé c'est à mon
avis moi c'est une aide à la grande
distribution c'est pas une aide aux
consomme au consommateur c'est pas eux
qui vont bénéficier de cette aide là
pour rester dans les réponses apportées
au mouvement dit gilles et jo ni celles
qui sont liées aux racines entendu sur
l'image et donc demander plus de
démocratie plus de participation est ce
qu'il faut faire pour la démocratie ce
que le conseil consultatif citoyen
proposé par l'agencé est une bonne
réponse est ce que il faut aller plus
loi censée c'est déjà une réponse
nous ce qu'on propose peut-être sur pc à
faire parler de nos propositions
on propose nous à la réunion que les
solutions aux problèmes soient écrites
par les réunionnais et donc à travers
d'une assemblée une assemblée
territoriale qui serait ouverte non
seulement aux politiques aux élus mais
aussi à aux autres acteurs -enfin de la
réunion donc là ça permettrait à plus de
personnes de participer aux décisions
qui touchent la réunion donc là ça
ferait partie de cette proposition
je lis portable vous avez été choisi
pour figurer sur la liste donc présenté
par le parti communiste français 06 mai
prochain en sixième position sur cette
liste conduite je lisais par ian brossât
jouer la mairie de paris
qu est ce que vous êtes retrouvé un peu
de questions alors déjà peut-être un
petit mot pour expliquer que le mode de
scrutin pour les élections européennes a
changé c'est un essai le nouveau
gouvernement qui a proposé sa jusqu'à
présent il y avait des listes pan
circonscriptions il y avait une
circonscription outre-mer par bassin est
comme ça on avait l'assurance d'avoir
trois élus issus des dom donc abbas un
océan indien
abbas a pacifié puis pour martine voilà
donc on avait trois élus issus des dom
là avec le nouveau gouvernement a
proposé de ramener à une seule
circonscription
donc pour que les personnes des dom les
réunionnais les ventes uniques et soit
élu ben il faut que ces personnes là
soit sur des listes nationales et
nouveau pca vous voyez bien on peut pas
se présenter au niveau national on est
un parti régional parti communiste
réunionnais donc notre seule chance de
d'avoir d'avoir un élu c'est d'être
présent sur une liste nationale
et c'est là que le pcf a été d'une
grande solidarité
je dirais envers les réunionnais et à
travers le pc puisque le pcf nous a
proposé d'être représentés sur sa liste
et donc nous avons accepté et ils nous
ont mis en sixième position
c'est en plus du manque de solidarité
c'est une marque de confiance là pour le
pcr parce que quand même sur 79 2 places
et 6e c'est vraiment une proposition
très correct et historiquement troisième
femme en plus bon c'est historique pour
les liens entre le pcf ont pas toujours
et c'est très simple si ni très clair
est ce que vous êtes sur une même ligne
politique globale a pas très sympa très
clair mais tout simplement parce que ce
sont deux partis communistes qui se
respecte tout simplement le parti
communiste contrairement à d'autres
partis france est un
c'est le seul parti qui respecte les
partis qui sont dans les dom le parti
communiste français défend les intérêts
du peuple français et il comprend très
bien qu'à la réunion il ya un parti
communiste réunionnais qui défend le
peuple réunionnais et en ce sens le
parti communiste réunionnais à sa vision
et en aucun cas il ya interférence il ya
aucun cas en aucun cas il ya un manque
de respect de la part des deux parties
donc il se peut effectivement que nous
ne soyons pas sur la même longueur
d'onde
et ben c'est ça arrive on n'est pas en
français on a ici notre vision et c'est
tout à fait normal qu'on n'est pas du
tout on n'est pas en france on a dit on
n'est pas sur le continent français donc
c'est normal que nous ayons une vision
réunionnaise c'est normal que le pcf
comprennent ça et que nous soyons on
comprenne la position du pcf
donc il n'ya pas même si on n'a pas la
même vision il ya quand même un grand
respect de la part des deux parties n'a
ouvert en 2017 et ses complices dans un
exercice classique sous les couleurs de
la france insoumise il faut vous serez
en confiance une liste proposée par la
france soumise il serait qu'elles
figurent par ailleurs le député européen
sortant
une somme argile
donc après imposition qui lui-même est
un ancien du pcr il avait succédé à
suivre aussi c'est compliqué alors petit
une petite précision en 2017 j'étais
candidate de l'union pca france a soumis
souffrance a soumises pcg j'avais mon
étiquette de pca avec nous il y avait
les assauts le suppléant était la france
est soumise et je dois dire qu'on a
travaillé parfaitement dans dans une
union centriste a fait campagne pour
vous et j'ai fait campagne aussi avec la
france a soumis jeudi qu' on sait on
sait parfaitement entendu il y avait des
règles des deux côtés les deux parties
ont respecté les règles de chacun et là
vraiment on a fait le travail et c'est
pas ça c'est que ont déjà on a fait un
traité pour très bon travail et on a
travaillé ensemble
je n'ai jamais là-dessus il n'y a pas de
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de procès à
faire vous pourrez demander à tous ceux
qui sont en salle denis on a vraiment
fait un travail en collectif et ça s'est
très bien passé on a eu un résultat
aussi qu'ils étaient très concentrés
voilà c'était très honorable on avait
face à nous quand même pour le satan
c'était à ce contrat maintenant ce n'est
plus la même élection
là on est dans un cadre national vous
avez vu on n'est pas le pc c'est vrai
que yunus est parti avec la france a
soumise mais le pca est un portier le pc
est apathique et un parti doit exister
doit pouvoir défendre ses cités et ne
peut pas s'arrêter
à une personne donc il fallait que le
pca soit présent et c'est le cas et que
le pca soit présenté le les membres du
parti à la réunion m'ont proposé je suis
dans un parti et je respecte
parfaitement les décisions qui sont
prises et je suis aussi d'accord avec
cette décision
maintenant je pense on va être en alors
en concurrence et je pense que c'est
c'est pas tout à fait le mot vous avez
parlé vous n'êtes pas encore mais on
parle souvent des sondages et on voit
bien que la france est soumise est
actuellement créditée de 7 8% et avec
7,8 poissant ils ont largement la
possibilité d'avoir sept à huit élus et
younousse omarjee étant de liège en
quatrième position sur cette liste
nous pensons que automatiquement lui
sera réélu il sera réélu ça veut dire
que vous souhaitez que votre liste en
réalité de 2 2% sur les ondes à ce
niveau là non justement
justement ce que je demande moi aux
électeurs réunionnais c'est de faire en
sorte que la liste qui est présentée pas
qu'ils aient mené par ian brossât la
liste du pcf fasse un très bon score à
la réunion pour permettre un deuxième là
en l'occurrence une femme à une deuxième
personne ce sondage les autres mais
quand vous quand vous faites le total
avec le nid au niveau national ça ne va
pas enlever une poussière je pense sur
le résultat de la france a soumises
si à la réunion par contre on fait un
résultat honorable
ça permettra au score du pcf d'augmenter
et d'atteindre peut-être les cinq points
qui permettront pcf d'avoir des élus
globalement la gauche là où joue en
france par extrêmement division cette
élection où il n'y a pas eu d'accord
avec avec avec le tout les cinq listes
être de 2,7 au premier risque de laisser
finalement la droite libérale et parti
nationaliste gouvernorat pour les 100
prochaines années
alors malheureusement effectivement
comme vous dites y'a pas eu d'entente et
comme vous et comme d'autres
d'autres personnes non je le regrette on
peut tous leur prêter maintenant les
choses sont ce qu'elles sont c'est à
nous de nous battre pour que notre
projet à nous soit soit entendu par la
population
mais effectivement on aurait pu
souhaiter que toutes les mouvances de
gauche s'entendent pour faire une liste
effectivement il n'ya pas de là dessus
je vous reprocher parce que vous avez
dit que que comme moi vous le rôle moi
je ne fais que des mets que donner les
faits quelle europe est ce que vous avez
tenté de proposer les tories ont c'est
parce que les difficultés d'intéresser
la réunion à ce scrutin mais doit
manquer auquel le rat que vous souhaitez
aurait alors vous vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la halle à ce qui est proposé
par le pcf c'est une europe plus sociale
l'europe des gens pas l'europe de
l'argent nous à la réunion bien sûr nous
nous sommes sur cette liste et nous
respectons nous nous accordons
parfaitement avec ce qui est proposé et
nous sommes nous à la réunion d'où nous
défendrons bien sûr des projets propres
à la réunion c'est le but d'avoir quand
même des réunionnais au parlement
européen donc par exemple tout à l'heure
je vous disais on est pour une assemblée
territoriale avec des compétences
élargies s'est pas levée c'est pas au
parlement
non non tout à fait que vous avez raison
mais pour que cette cette assemblée
puisse fonctionner il faut des fonds
donc ce qu'on propose aussi qui est un
fonds réunionnais un fonds de
développement réunionnais et là pendant
ce qu'on peut proposer ce qu'on peut
demander à l'europe c'est que les fonds
qui sont attribués par l'europe soit
globalisé et envoyé dans ce fonds de
développement parce que actuellement il
ya actuellement il ya beaucoup d'argent
qui rentre de l'europe mais cet argent
est ce qu on sait combien après
or sans allonger les chiffres environ
trois cents 300 millions d'euros par an
et s'étend un milliard + alors j'avais
les chiffres c'est pas grave
donc vous dites à peu près 300 millions
par an viennent dans différentes
cultures pour l'aviculture vous avez
pour le fonds social européen pour
l'aide à l'emploi aux jeunes a donc fait
des beaucoup de deux fonds qui arrive à
la réunion mais donc quand je disais de
300 millions pas en c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas peu mais ces fonds là sont
dirigés sont fléchés de l'europe à
partir de là bas doc c'est de là bas qui
décide où vont aller les fonds mais sur
des courses locale papa tout à fait
c'est quand même là bas c'est quand même
de la bac on décide donc nous ce qu'on
propose justement c'est que cet argent
arrive à la réunion dans ce fonds de
développement réunionnais et que c'est à
la réunion puisque c'est à la réunion
convie les problèmes que c'est à la
réunion aux réunionnais de trouver les
solutions et c'est aux réunionnais de
diriger cet argent là donc la sas et
c'est une première revendication en
europe accepte rethel de distribuer nos
impôts sans avoir un oeil sur la façon
pour cet argent dépensé sûr on ne
demande pas on ne demande pas que
l'europe ferme les yeux sur
l'utilisation que l'europe fasse des
contrôles sas et c'est tout à fait tout
à fait normal c'est parce qu'on demande
que en face la proposition à l'europe et
qu'ils accordent l'europe
bien sûr là il n'ya pas y'a pas de
soucis mais quand même que les
propositions émanent de la réunion c'est
ça c'est ça surtout la revendication du
parti communiste réunionnais ce après
effectivement bien sûr pourquoi elle
accepterait de donner de l'argent comme
ça
bien sûr que non l'équipe y ait des
contrôles que qui est un regard avant
l'utilisation bien sûr y'a pas il n'y a
pas de souci mais quand même que tout ne
soit pas décidée là bas à bruxelles quoi
il n'y a pas essai c'est surtout ça le
souci le vouliez parler d'autonomie et
d'une assemblée territoriale
là on ne sait pas l'europe c'est plutôt
au niveau national que ça se déciderait
c'est que ce serait quoi une assemblée
unique
l'agent ça peut être ça peut prendre
cette forme là ça peut être une
assemblée avec quand je vous disais
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
d'autres acteurs que les acteurs
politiques qui pourraient rentrer dans
dans ce set a semblé point décidée pour
les réunionnais et vous dites que c'est
pas l'europe qui qui peut mettre ça en
oeuvre effectivement mais pas en compte
cette assemblée peut avoir des
compétences élargies par exemple la
compétence de discuter avec nos voisins
nous sommes quand même dans l'océan
indien et actuellement nous n'avons pas
cette compétence là par contre l'europe
elle elle le fait elle avec les ape les
accords de partenariat économique
l'europe peut aller discuter et passer
des contrats économiques avec les pays
de la zone donc là ça ça peut être une
revendication pour cette assemblée que
des réunionnais soient présents quand il
y à ses discussions avec les pays de la
zone parce qu'actuellement nous ben on
subit les les
les contrats qui sont qui sont passés
avec les pays et les nouveaux
entrepreneurs ils savent pas ce qui se
passe et on ne peut même pas défendre le
point de vue des réunionnais peut pas
défendre nos acteurs économiques ici
donc ça par contre ça ça peut entrer ça
c'est une revendication d'un député
européen ça il peut le faire
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
convaincre les électeurs réunionnais de
se déplacer pour aller voter en ce 26
mai prochain je vous refais des mères
par ailleurs ce que vous comprenez la
réticence des électeurs à l'europe d'une
part et puis et puis tout simplement la
méfiance vis-à-vis du système
d'échographie tel qu'il est de 2
question effectivement concernant
l'europe
c'est le taux le plus bas enfin pour que
les gens fassent passion c'était 15 fois
sans la dépasser
et là c'est effectivement là le jeune la
fête des mères donc ce n'est pas évident
parce que c'est loin aussi il ne voit
pas vraiment là terry ne vois pas ce que
ça apporte par dont on parlait des fonds
des 300 millions qui rentrent ils ne
voient pas où ça part tout ça donc pour
eux c'est loin et c'est normal c'est pas
seulement en france c'est pas seulement
à la réunion en français c'est pareil
c'est quelque chose qui est loin pour
les réunionnais donc c'est à nous qui
sommes sur les listes d'aller vers les
réunionnais d'aller
faire ce qu'il faut pour qu' il soit au
courant par exemple cette on a commencé
cette semaine a commencé samedi à faire
une première réunion on a fait à saint
leu et et effectivement les personnes me
disaient avant de commencer mais
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on voit
exactement c'est quoi exactement mais tu
fais quoi là dedans il faut expliquer
aux personnes faire un travail vraiment
de pédagogie pour aller expliquer aux
personnes à quoi correspond ce cette
élection est pourquoi il faut aller il
faut aller voter jeudi pontalba est
l'invité de la vie politique
je suis content dans l'europe que
défendre votre liste union défense des
services publics il est plutôt à rebours
de la tendance libérale qui quasi soit
inscrite dans les traités européens qui
préconise la libre concurrence dans le
secteur est ce que vous croyez que le
parlement européen décidé demain d'une
autre orientation politique que celle
qui est qu'il te en cours actuellement
basse il ya une grosse majorité de
personnes qui sont à gauche et qui
pensent comme nous c'est possible parce
que au parlement européen une voix et
une voix un député a porté à prendre une
voie donc c'est à la population aussi on
comprend les les revendications mais
c'est la population aussi d'aller voter
et d'aller voter pour les personnes qui
portent leur projet donc il ya les
choses peuvent changer peuvent toujours
changer en parlant de de l'orientation
des budgets pour la fonction publique
il ya aussi quelque chose que nous ont
portés au pca c'est la bataille pour le
climat on va on va venir on vend pendant
un instant mais pour rester sur sur
cette défense des services publics on
sait bien que que c'est une bataille qui
se joue au niveau national aussi au
niveau européen parce que aujourd'hui la
priorité du gouvernement c'est
visiblement plutôt de lutter contre le
déficit public et donc de ré
dépenses publiques commenceront à sa
tendance comment est-ce qu'on paye
comment être aux finances aujourd'hui
les services publics mais je crois que
c'est sans augmenter les impôts il faut
il faut revoir la les comment on dirige
l'agencé
c'est aux personnes qui sont à
l'assemblée nationale a semblé au
parlement européen de revoir le fléchage
de l'argent c'est pas si les personnes
qui sont là défendre une économie
libérale
forcément ils vont orienter l'argent
dans ce sens messi et des personnes qui
sont là comme ceux du parti communiste
défendre plutôt une europe sociale
vous voyez bien que les sous ne sont pas
orientées de la même manière votre liste
veut proposer une approche je souhaite
une approche sociale de la transition
écologique ça veut dire quoi
alors comme je disais il faut réorienter
l'argent donc actuellement vous savez
l'année passée on a fait venir à la
réunion
larrouturou qui avait que jean jouzel
pierre loup rajot voilà composent impact
climat et dans ce pacte climat il
propose que l'argent soit dégagée pour
favoriser justement encourager le
travail contre les effets du changement
climatique faire face aux effets du
changement climatique
encourager la biodiversité et dans ce
pacte climat l'argent qui est dégagée
justement serait pour aller vers
l'emploi dans ce domaine donc là c'est
une façon de d'orienter l'argent
autrement oui il n'ya pas c'est l'idée
de une des idées de carlao tout ça c'est
de créer une banque publique du climat
une banque européenne qui permettrait
d'apporter instance en plus calés dans
les différents domaines de lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique qui créent
les emplois
concrètement à la réunion on en est une
idée de ce que ça pourrait donner
on parle de deux poissons du pib donc
calculer le
bien que psa pourrait est bon mais j'ai
pas les chiffres pour la réunion jeu est
globalement l'idée c'est de dehors de
l'argent public au niveau européen pour
créer les emplois créés des emplois dans
des domaines particuliers
alors ils disent pour favoriser la
transition vers une économie à forte
efficacité énergétique est faible en
carbone en protégeant la biodiversité
nous ici on avait proposé la création
par exemple de deux grands services dont
un service dédié à l'environnement
et là on peut comptabiliser des milliers
d'emplois tout ce qui est protection de
l'environnement
protection de nos forêts protection de
la biodiversité marine
il ya énormément de d'emplois est donc
là par exemple là c'est dans ce sens là
on pourrait orienter cet argent les
auditeurs peuvent nous appeler un an
cinq minutes on reprendra d'éventuelles
questions pour notre invité julie
pontalba qui figure comme en 16e
position sur la liste pour les
européennes la liste présentée par le
parti communiste français avec donc du
pcr à l'intérieur sur les les vous avez
évoqué dans les ape les négociations sur
les relations régionales
c'est un point sur lequel le pcr a
toujours milité
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
changer au niveau du règlement derrière
actuelle européen pour que la réunion
ait son mot à dire sur ses relations
internationales mais actuellement la
réunion n'a absolument pas de moi dias
et au niveau européen quand de sic on
décide de qui va aller rencontrer les
dirigeants de tel ou tel pays et à aucun
moment la réunion n'est ni consultée
donc il faudrait déjà que l'on puisse
faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
représentant je ne sais pas le
représentant de le président de région
ou mais qui est quelqu'un de la région
de la réunion qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient présentes vous parler d'autonomie
toujours beaucoup même si c'était un
témoin entendu beaucoup plus l'époque de
paul vergès l'autre mais ça veut dire
aussi alors le sujet peut-être plus
franco-français mais c'est la fin d'un
monde dont virapoullé ça passe aussi par
leur âme et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est fondamentalement qui est évident il
faut absolument enlevé 7
cet amendement qui nous empêche vraiment
de faire des choses qu'ils soient
spécifiquement réunionnaise bon là
dessus il n'y a pas de
là-dessus pareil a pas de mystère c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
enlever et maintenant toute façon ce
n'est plus que le pca qui le dit c'est
quasiment toute la classe politique
réunionnaise qui qui va dans ce sens
dans les attributions de l'europe et des
aides européennes on en parlait il ya
l'agriculture dans cette question qui
revient régulièrement sur tapis sylla et
non est-ce qu'il faut orienter
aujourd'hui c'est est d'avis que
l'européenne toujours vers la can ce
qu'il faut aller vers la diversification
comment qu'elle est là la position du pc
de votre liste du pcf alors encore une
fois c'est aux réunionnais de décider et
c'est à eux de se réunir pour en décider
par exemple ce samedi quand on parlait
de ça il y avait quelqu'un qui était
agriculteur qui nous disait moi ici je
suis agriculteur en perçoit normalement
des aides mais je ne vois jamais comment
ces aides sont orientés comment on les
distribue
c'est quelque chose qui est floue même
pour les agriculteurs même ceux qui
perçoivent czc flou pour beaucoup
d'entre eux donc il faut absolument que
ce soit beaucoup plus clair et que ce
soit fait ici à la réunion on a du monde
au standard on à virgile du port qui
nous appellent bonjour virgin
bonjour messieurs bonjour mon sentiment
concernant ces élections européennes on
vous écoute et julie pontalba vous
n'êtes pas la première veillée unione où
régnera la première yeux et
personnalités de la réunion qui filait
au sein du pcf au tout depuis paul
vergès ont 79 sont bons il était
quatrième sur la liste de jean leman c
est ça a permis à paul vergès le sont
aussi aujourd'hui on avait la
possibilité de faire un récapitulatif de
plus qu'il a pu avoir au niveau du
parlement européen ce serait bon aussi
pour les réunionnais quotidien y voter
mais moi je veux revenir sur la première
question qui vous a été posée concernant
les gilets
nous je veux dire que jusqu'à ces
dernières années là l'organisation qui
menait les luttes ici la réunion c'était
le pcr est amené pas mal de combats et
il s'était les combats victorieux avec
la population et moi j'ai le souvenir
qu'en penser à 10 et la nature a horreur
du vide se vide blessés aujourd'hui par
le pcr combat aujourd'hui il yad'autres
qui essayent de s'engouffrer dans avec
toutes les avec tout le monde toutes les
revendications qu'ils comptent même si
ces preuves cdc s'est désorganisée benzé
lors aux engrais de voir tout ça est de
voir aujourd'hui un pcr ben on sait il
faut dire les choses comme les uns on
s'est autodétruit en or s'est
autodétruit nous-mêmes et résultat
aujourd'hui ben les gens sont désemparés
se prend pas ainsi qu'on avait un rayon
qui ont mené des luttes concernant
l'égalité sociale par exemple toutes les
grandes avancées qu'on a eu
et bien aujourd'hui à vide des celui
d'aujourd'hui ben il tout le monde veut
essayer d'occuper par le biais des idées
gilet jaune mais c'est dommage je pense
que il ya les élections européennes qui
va arriver
ben je dis à la population et aux gens
qui nous écoutent mais il faut pas se
décroiser il faut envoyer à l'assemblée
européenne des gens qui sont vraiment
pour y occuper des problèmes de la
réunion ou merci pourquoi de ces
personnes merci virgile élèves et vous
remercie de votre soutien
on sent bien voilà et que finalement les
gilet jaune aujourd'hui il a la nature a
horreur du vide voilà c'est à dire que
le parti communiste réunionnais n'est
plus le référent dans la lutte sociale
alors d'abord je voudrais remercier
via gilles du port et post pour son
soutien et pour ce qu'il a dit et je
ressens un peu son émotion parce que je
comprends ce qu'il dit on est de la même
avis hein c'est vraiment je comprends ce
qu'il dit à cet instant concernant
d'abord les réalisations du du camarade
paul effectivement il a été élu pour la
première fois c'était le premier vote en
1979 sur la liste du pcf prise de
quitter comme ça n'est pas que georges
marchais et il a été réélu après
plusieurs fois il a fait effectivement
il a réalisé beaucoup notamment les rup
qui reconnaît des spécificités les
autres voilà les régions ultra
périphériques comme la réunion eh ben ça
ça vient d'une proposition
2 paul vergès et voilà un travail qu'il
a fait et qui est aujourd'hui qu'on ne
peut plus revenir parce que c'était
tellement important
donc effectivement il a fait énormément
pour le climat ou s'il a fait énormément
je vais je vais venir à auch il est
jeune donc il a raison de rappeler
l'histoire du portier de rappeler qu' il
ya des communistes qui ont fait beaucoup
pour pour aider la réunion ensuite la
concernant les gilets jaunes
c'est vrai que le parti communiste n'a
pas pris n'a pas pris les devants mais
c'était aussi une revendication des
gilet jaune
au début il ne voulait pas de que les
politiques entrent dans ce mouvement il
ne voulait pas de récupérer il ne
croyait pas il ne croit plus aux
politiques
et voilà il ne croit plus politique et
je crois que le pc a été on aurait pu
faire des conférences de presse en parle
et fait des cheveux mais je pense qu'on
a été on a voulu vraiment respectée
ce que demande et l'élégie les jeunes
est jamais que ce soit moi ou d'autres
on est allé et faire du racolage vais
essayer de faire de détourner des
personnes jamais on a on a toujours
respecté le mouvement des jeunes on
ad'autant plus respecté que ce que
disent les jets les jeunes c'est aussi
ce que nous nous disons depuis très
longtemps que à la réunion ça ne va plus
qu'il faut changer le système qu'il faut
qu'on parle tous ensemble et on n'est
pas contradictoire mais on ne dit pas
différemment dg les jeunes et mais c'est
juste que je pense qu'il ya quand même
un grand respect las de ce que demande
et les jets les jeunes nous allons au
standard où lulu du port est avec nous
bonjour non seulement ils problématique
que la dgta l'évoqué pas leur là mais en
plus il est ce que vous avez vu députés
au parlement aucun ace qui la font on
m'a taillé pour la responsabilité du
patrimoine est au sein de la république
française bien sûr mais également de
l'union européenne mais aussi au sein de
la coi commission de l'océan indien pour
abonder longtemps régional solidaire et
merci merci pour votre question c'est
lucien plus witting du du parti
communiste régnerait qu'yves qui
rappelle cet engagement là alors bien
sûr tout à faire on l'a dit tout à
l'heure à notre combat il et il est bien
sûr réunionnais s'est on défend on est à
la réunion on est là pour défendre les
projets des intérêts de la réunion
concernant le sait en interne zone de
paix je remercie dans d'en parler sans
être élu au parlement européen
je me bats déjà auprès des personnes de
la zone
je suis au sein du mouvement réunionnais
pour la paix qui se bat tous les jours
pour un océan indien zone de paix on a
été aux côtés de nos amis chagossiens on
a été aux côtés de nos amis seychellois
qui sont contre l'installation d'une
base militaire aux seychelles donc même
sans être élu il y a des choses à faire
que l'on peut faire et je suis déjà dans
cette action-là andré nous appelle du
sud rejoindrait dans un coach allez-y
quand on prend la rébellion parce que je
suis la région si ce n'est pas encore
fait rayons pour l'europe
et voilà france dans sud de l'océan
indien
est-ce que les rayonnements non
seulement la france mais l'europe toute
surface maritime et sachant pertinemment
que le juriste plus la méditerranée
l'art se défend ce mondial c'est l'océan
indien et les continua gagne 2 man avec
l'europe avec la france compte tenu de
la distance et les langes ce dont il
reçoit il faudra nous la peau des fesses
en plus free soissons de fours sont plus
chers ici qu'ailleurs car les pro bowl
bien sûr alors que si vous regardez où
là où est loin de l'autre côté la chine
possède l'afrique déjà et l'afrique
constitue quand même le le continent le
plus riche de la planète
la fille déjà vous aviez promis d'être
rapide andré vous aviez dit que vous
seriez très rapide je voudrais poser
votre question à julie pour tabasser
double la réunion se nourrit de chine et
de l'inde
on s'est dit qu'on sa vie on construit
et puis en consomme chinois et ceci
malgré les barrières et la barrière
financière kfw frontalière alors me
demande que jamais un préfet encore avec
l'europe
beausoleil avant ça veut dire qu'on la
métropolisation pour nous ne négligeons
qu'avait déjà il continue à notre
colonisation les gagne encore bel
exemple merci merci pour votre
intervention andré qu'est ce que est ce
que finalement la notion porte-avions
réunion porte avions qui parlent de paix
juste avant c'était pas le move qui nous
parle plus mais on doit l'europe a tout
intérêt à avoir la réunion européenne
l'europe certainement oui mais à la
réunion nous on n'est pas est-ce qu'on
nous on doit se battre pour garder ceux
des bases militaires à la réunion où
dans la zone certainement pas nous avons
toujours été un des pays pacifiques
je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
chose pour nous d'avoir ce genre de base
dans nos pays une dernière question
rapidement de jf qui nous appellent de
l'est bonjour je menais de poser une
autre question rapidement et je voudrais
rapidement ses notes personnelles en fin
d'émission
il est moribond respect donc d'empêcher
les gens de ces défis novembre seulement
et les gilets jaunes sont à partie nous
ne ne se sent pas de nous sommes pas un
parti politique pas qu'on faisait
maintenant nous nous rendons compte ou
faisons la politique mais chaque chose
en son temps
everett justement ce que le temps nous
manque on me dit pas juste demandé à
madame ce qu'elle pense du riq jeu
référendum d'initiative citoyenne est ce
que ça elle sera elle sera être que ça
s'appelle
deux tueries merci merci j'ai fait pour
votre question donc une réponse tout à
fait positive a bien sûr je suis pour
j'ai assisté à des dates des assemblées
où on en parlait donc je suis tout à
fait pour et je ne pense pas que le
camarade qui appelait tout à l'heure a
voulu mettre en opposition les il est
jeune et le pca c'est juste pour dire
que on est quand même sur le même le
même discours est depuis des années on
dit la même chose
tout simplement ça et que vraiment il ya
un respect du pca par rapport à leur
mouvement et que jamais il ya eu
d'interférence de notre part il n'y a
pas de on ne dit pas autre chose juste
très rapidement sur le référendum estime
citoyenne vous êtes plutôt pour cette
démocratie directe plutôt qu'une
démocratie participative parce qu'il ya
une nuance quand même qui entrent
je pense qu'il ya effectivement il ya
une nuance mais peut-être qu'il faut
aussi
il est possible d'avoir les deux
d'adapter pour que tout le monde puisse
y trouver son compte en dans plus de
démocratie parce que c'est ce que les
gens disent aujourd'hui ils ont
l'impression de ne pas pouvoir
participer de ne pas avoir leur place
que tout est déjà fait tout ce qui peut
être fait pour que les personnes
puissent s'exprimer
deux dates être prises en compte merci
beaucoup julie pontalba d'avoir été
l'invité de lundi politique
demain à la même heure ce sera le club
de la presse passer une journée sur la
première
[Musique]
le conseil consultatif citoyen c'est
quoi c'est une instance de
représentation de la société civile
consultés par le conseil régional en
toute transparence sur des sujets
d'intérêt général et qui peut participer
tous les réunionnais motivés et
volontaires peuvent être membres du ccc
sur tirage au sort d'huissier cap
citoyens réunion c'est la nouvelle plate
forme qui donne la parole aux
réunionnais rendez vous sur
www.capifrance.fr et donner votre avis
jusqu'au 5 mars
alors tu fais quoi maintenant que
thalbach le gci l'école de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la réunion
tu connais ses business school une école
100% connectés entreprises pour
décrocher son bachelor projet
entreprises challenge en équipe stage à
l'étranger
c'est tout ça le gc réunion à ton tour
de vibrer pendant trois ans
et toi à l'école de gestion et de
commerce qui veut plus d'infos vient la
journée portes ouvertes le samedi 9 mars
de 9h à 17h une école de la cci réunion
lancé par l'europe et la région réunion
l'hôpital gabriel martin de saint-paul
déminage les 5 et 6 mars vers le centre
hospitalier ouest réunion le shore
pendant cette période nous vous invitons
à consulter votre médecin traitant en
première intention et bien sûr pour les
urgences fait le 15 afin d'être orientés
vers une structure adaptée
toutes nos activités de soins reprennent
dès le 7 mars au shore votre nouvel
hôpital de l'ouest à cambaie en france
on aime débattre de tout discuter
échanger confronter nos points de vue
sur les sujets d'aujourd'hui comme ceux
de demain avec le grand débat national
tous les avis compte vous avez jusqu'au
15 mars pour participer près de chez
vous ou sur grand débat point fr le
grand débat national
transformons ensemble vos propositions
en solutions amour douceur passion la
voix des femmes à l'honneur
en français ou en créole laissez vous
emporter par la douce poésie des loti
lorette et les sonorités jazz maloya de
gwendoline absalon sur une scène
partagée mars à 20h au théâtre lucet
langenier saint-pierre et bouge
le conseil consultatif citoyen c'est
quoi c'est une instance de
représentation de la société civile
consultés par le conseil régional en
toute transparence sur des sujets
d'intérêt général et qui peut participer
tous les réunionnais motivés et
volontaires peuvent être membres du ccc
sur tirage au sort d'huissier cap
citoyens réunion c'est la nouvelle plate
forme qui donne la parole aux
réunionnais rendez vous sur
www.capifrance.fr et donner votre avis
jusqu'au 5 mars
merci d'écouter à la première dans deux
petites minutes il sera 13 heures
rendez-vous avec les titres de france
info et puis cet après midi on chante
sonia bonjour oui où chante comme
d'habitude chez page 1 sont pas
terribles à dans les oreilles oui ça va
bien bien mais oui on chante on se
rappelle de bons souvenirs parce que
l'épopée on les jette à toulouse danse
et le jazz et la java
tu verras on ira au cinéma et puis
rencontré cécile ma fille et petite
fille je suis pas sous le par contre non
c'est marie gallet sous il faut tourner
la page
bombay dans ce surmoi n'ont pas non non
non plus non plus recevoir et vous avez
reconnu un petit peu le le répertoire
bien sûr de claude nougaro et s'il ya
déjà quinze ans vous rendez contre 1,70
passe vite vraiment ça va vite trop vite
le de nogaro un jour un artiste et puis
demain
véronique sens si les gens veulent de a
déjà commandé leur chandelle cher
sondeurs ironique demain voilà si belle
commande et enfin pas trop quand même
pas cher des poèmes frais de port et par
contre vendredi à l'heure vendredi ce
sera la journée de la femme mais à mon
avis ça va être